did you know that you don't have to pay
taxes you could move to another country
and pay zero taxes legally you might
have already seen my interview with
wealthy expat who does exactly this for
you they've helped over 500 crypto
investors and entrepreneurs like Iman
gaji lower their taxes down to zero
percent legally and you could do this
too in as little as two weeks well the
expat will hold your hand through the
entire process setting you up in a
tax-free country like Dubai with the
help of tax experts lawyers and
accountants if you're interested in
paying zero percent taxes make sure to
book a free call with wealthy expat
using my link in the description below I
hope you enjoyed this insightful
interview please don't forget to hit the
like button and subscribe today I'm
joined by an entrepreneur who
specializes in digital marketing he's an
agency owner and a founder of one of the
world's largest online education
companies he's very much involved in the
crypto industry and has been very vocal
in some of the crazy issues that's going
on in the world today he was born in
Dagestan and moved to the United Kingdom
at a very young age Iman gaji welcome to
the show how are you doing I'm doing
great thank you very much for having me
absolute pleasure I've been so excited
to um have you on the show I can't
believe everything that you've done
you're only 22.
um that blows my mind
um but before we get into everything you
actually said before we started the show
this is gonna be one of the last
podcasts you do why is that I don't know
I think I'm sure as you know I've seen
you on a lot of podcasts recently as
well um sometimes you usually I didn't
do a podcast for a couple years and
sometimes you Clump a lot of podcasts
together and then they end up just very
repetitive uh obviously I can tell
you're very very well researched but you
know sometimes people aren't and you end
up just talking about the same stuff so
I don't know I just kind of feel as I
need to go dark go live my life for
another two three years go do some more
things that are worth talking about and
then you know come back and share so
yeah I decided this will probably be my
last podcast for the next couple years
wow I'm honest and that means we have a
lot to get through if you're gonna go
dark for the next two years so let's do
this I really want to start um at the
very beginning I want to talk about your
upbringing um moving from Dagestan to
the United Kingdom at such a young age
what was that like and also what was it
like growing up in London with your mum
um you know moving from from that that
kind of situation what was it like
growing up with your mum from the photos
that I see of me when I'm young in
Pakistan I looked very happy uh and yeah
my uh biological father you know he
wasn't around alcoholic abusive whatever
just a very common story so actually I
was born and my mom used to work three
jobs so my grandma took care of me my
grandma and my grandpa in the house that
my grandpa built with his own two hands
uh he was a army soldier and this is all
stuff that's very very common in
Pakistan especially around that time so
yeah I think I had no context for
anything different you know simple
things like not having a toilet having
to take our you know come out the uh the
main entrance take a right right pass
the chickens the cows it's like this
little like uh you know wooden Shack
thing you you know squat do your thing
go back
um between stuff like that nine black
and white channels like it was just
normal and I think it was very a happy
healthy existence uh also
a very happy healthy existence in the
sense that no real sugar when I was you
know when I was young no real sugar
no certain things injected into my arms
just a very happy healthy in my opinion
as it should be childhood so I went from
that to you know moving to London
and you know uh going on my first flight
everyone I was four years old and just
getting to London having 999 color
channels just like it's a very going to
the supermarket and seeing all this like
bright green bright red sugary candy and
just feeling like a drug addict
instantly so you know just life was very
different you know having my first sip
of Coca-Cola oh wow like just really
like you know there are certain things
that I remember certain things that I
see photos of
um so I don't know it was just a it was
a very interesting change it was uh
taking someone who was you know pretty
much a little village boy and having to
educate them learning things like you
know how to hold a knife and fork
properly you know that's not to say that
you know where I'm from people have
absolutely no manners but I think it's
just when you're four years old when
you're six years old it's not expected
that you need to be you know have
correct table manners and know what to
do and this and that and then going to
London you know it's a very different
story
so it was just a it was an interesting
juxtaposition that's for sure why did
you move uh so my mom met my stepdad uh
when I was two years old in Moscow they
started dating for a couple years she
moved to London for I think it was three
four months to basically just trial
living together you know and you know
they were happy things were going well
So eventually they got married we moved
to London and um yeah it was meant to be
a fairy tale story unfortunately it
didn't quite end out that way
um yeah my stepdad was a very uh
very tortured Soul uh that's for sure so
he I think he'd been through a lot of
very very difficult stuff when he was
growing up he went to boarding school
and he was four years old he'd been
through a lot of abuse in his life
um so yeah he wasn't uh he wasn't a very
happy man so I had a weird childhood
where I went to London I lived in London
I lived in Chelsea which is a very
wealthy area uh in a house that was
worth three million dollars uh but had
no warm water no Heating and then you
know when my dad found my stepdad found
out that I was building a business he
cut off the Wi-Fi
um because he liked that we you know had
to be dependent on him for any scraps he
was a very wait explain this so you
lived in one of the wealthiest areas in
London
um but you didn't have any hot water and
then why does your stepdad cut off the
Wi-Fi
he was um I think he didn't he felt very
powerless growing up so he liked a
feeling of power and he liked the
feeling of power over us so that's I
mean I
a lot of people look at what I've done
and think it's very you know
extraordinary and I think I had the
right concoction of
things where I was in a wealthy area so
for me it was never a big deal you know
some people but you know photos of
Lamborghinis on their wallpaper uh and
the thing is they're
they put on such a pedestal and in their
mind they never deserve it whereas for
me like I would just see a Ferrari drive
by and I'm like okay well it's just a
car you know like it was just so
normalized to me and the other good
thing that uh that did for me was
I also went to school and I saw all my
friends parents who were so affluent and
were just [ __ ] miserable and it was
just they were miserable and my mom was
miserable and at some point when things
got really difficult me and my mom were
on government benefits so
I'm like your your reality is the exact
same it's just one has money and one
doesn't so it's just I learned a lot of
wisdom very very early on
um and I was very lucky that I had
wealth around me but none of it none of
it ourselves so I knew from an early age
either I did something for me and my mom
you know I have no siblings
um which I'm when I was young I really
didn't like now that I'm older for me
personally I love
um and yeah I don't want to know what it
would have been like if I had to take
care of someone else as well so
yeah I guess it was just the perfect
concoction all put together of like you
know I had the drive and it you know I
wish I could say I was some 12 year old
child genius I wasn't a 12 year old
child genius I was just a 12 year old
who was very cognizant and would used to
rummage around my mom's because she
would hide it from a rummage around to
check my mom's bank statements and I
would do calculations because I knew
what our outgoings were which were much
you know 1200 pounds a month
um which you know was like for her and
me and and also trying to maintain an
appearance of like we weren't flat broke
because that felt important to me to my
friends like there was always this thing
of like you know my close friends do and
I've my close friends
especially the ones that have been for
uh there you know right from the
beginning they've seen me
they've known all the struggles and
that's why I take care of them and I'll
take care of them for the rest of their
lives because they were the ones who you
know used to pay for my lunch but not
mention it to anyone else so you know I
didn't feel embarrassed or I didn't feel
out of place or if someone you know if
my friends invited me to cinema
obviously I couldn't afford to go but
you know I had certain friends of mine
that would spawn me but it wasn't just
about spotting me it was about the fact
that they wouldn't try to hold that
against me because they just knew I
couldn't do anything about the situation
I was in so yeah it was it was a very
interesting childhood
um but it was a very tormented childhood
but it was I guess it panned out okay
that's amazing that you had friends do
that that's that's like having a sibling
by the way yeah I've realized 100 I
think it's uh you get to obviously you
get to choose these people as well you
know you're not Bound by Blood and
I think that also taught me very early
on it's important to not it's important
not just to give because I had friends
of mine or people who I suppose were
friends or people around me that would
do it but would pity me for it and I
think
of all things in the world pity is
probably the worst thing to experience
to know that someone like genuinely like
looks down on you or like feels a sense
of superiority and uh it's funny I told
I said this in one of my uh a podcast I
did once
um you know uh I I I'll say I have an
Eastern European background like growing
up like my mom used to be the xiaomi
like that's it's just like a it's a
common thing like it's you know for some
people it sounds crazy and like when
you're easting European it's just it's
normal right
um and uh I had someone ask me would you
ever do that to your kid I'm like I will
never hit my kid uh I will never hit my
daughter ever ever my son the only time
I'll ever hit him is if he tries to use
my money as a means to feel Superior
against someone else
that is like to me because I know what
that's like to have other people use
their parents accomplishments as a way
to you know kind of box you in so I
think that also taught me a very
important lesson early on which is it's
not just about you know a boy gives and
wants other people to know and wants to
feel a sense of superiority over someone
or other people you know a man will just
give in silence
um or maybe not necessarily give in
silence but it's it's the frame that
it's coming and you know they're doing
it because they want to do it not
because they want to have a sense of
superiority or feel like they have you
know one up on someone so
I guess that told me a lesson as well
yeah no that's that's really fascinating
so it's was just you and your mum then
for a long time how did it become just
you and your mum and what's the
relationship like with you and your mom
because I see her on your Instagram and
she's now just dripping and like Chanel
and Louis Vuitton so you obviously have
a really special bond can you tell us
about that uh we have a very special
bond my mom is probably the person this
I don't think I've said this anywhere my
mom is probably the person I argue with
the most
um and I want everyone to know that my
mom gives absolutely zero [ __ ] about
anything I've accomplished she does not
care about my money in the slightest she
is the one person that I have no choice
but I have to listen to she's the one
person if someone if like if someone in
my life tries to dictate me or boss me
around and I know for a fact that I'm a
person where I will always listen to
other people's opinion but there's
certain areas and there's certain
domains I just know I know better than
you right and
my mom is the one person it does not
matter if she's if she tries to you know
Grill me about you know me paying my
employees too much or you know oh I
spend too much money or like she's my
mom she's my Russian mom and it does not
matter that she's 5'3 and I'm six foot
and I'm 22 now if cheapest if I piss her
off that's it like she'll she'll stretch
she'll just try to you know bring the
hand up and I'm like we're not doing
this Mom I'm 22 now
um so yeah you know
anyone who has an Eastern European mom
or I think like a middle eastern mom
they kind of understand uh what it's
like which is yeah it doesn't matter
what I accomplish in life she's very
proud of me but at the end of the day
she still views me as her son and as her
son whether I like it or not sometimes I
have to uh sit there and listen to her
now that's amazing that keeps you
grounded it keeps you keeps your value
strong
um out of interest you ever hear from
either real fathers
uh last time I heard from my stepdad was
uh in court uh when when I was 18 years
old which is it's I've always had a lot
I think one thing I'm very good at is I
always have a lot of foresight and I can
see where things are going and I told my
mom when I was 14 the day I turned 18 uh
you know my stepdad is gonna basically
kick us out the house and
that's what happened you know they
divorced his first request is you have
seven days to leave the house you've
been in for 14 years and um yeah growing
up my stepdad always used to watch his
favorite documentaries were War
documentaries Espionage documentaries he
was a very uh very powerful man and um
you know especially with us he'd like to
exert that power
um so that was the main reason I started
my business was because I knew I knew
from 14 I was saying I'm not going to go
to college because I knew that you know
it's not like I would have anyone to pay
for it and I wasn't going to take on
those sort of loans myself I at the age
of 14 I could tell that the ROI wasn't
there
wow so 14 you can see the ROI is not
there
I mean I don't I just think like
I think because I grew up very alone I
didn't because I grew up very alone
it was it was two parts I grew up very
alone and because my stepdad basically
made his life's mission to uh have my
self-esteem as low as humanly possible
uh I didn't particularly care too much
about what people thought about me and
that's I think also one of the reasons
I'm so outspoken and I don't I just I'll
say what I what I think and I don't care
if I believe it I don't really have a
filter and I've basically made my I've
insulated my life in a way where I can
say what I want and you know let's say
tomorrow whatever all my social media
accounts get Frozen and I I you know
people turn I couldn't care less you
know and I've always structured things
in a way where I want to be able to do
it I don't wanna
accomplish what I want in life doing it
someone else's way I want to be able to
do it my way and as I said I think a lot
of that stems from the fact that you
know when I was younger
um you know my self-esteem was so low
and I just didn't really feel like I had
anything to prove to anyone anyways so
when you can look at that especially
when you're wrong the main issue is
everyone's so afraid oh what are my
parents gonna think well I think I
couldn't care less oh what are my
friends gonna think well I couldn't care
less so when you can look at that you
know when you have nothing to lose then
you can look at things objectively you
know when you don't have anyone to
please you can look at things
objectively and objectively colleges one
of the biggest scams on Earth and for me
I guess at the age of 14 that was pretty
obvious yeah we'll get to all of that um
I want to hear your thoughts on why
universities are scam and all of that
but before we do
um you then started the YouTube grind
when you were 15 was it 15 or 14 15.
that's insane so how did you go from
grinding on YouTube doing those personal
training videos to essentially having a
seven seven figure social media
marketing agency how do you make that
transition
so once again it's just you always put
one foot forward in front of the other
so I because I didn't really I was a bit
of a almost a loner at school
um I started an Instagram account when I
was 14 years old called uh fcuk the norm
and it was like an anonymous account and
it was I would take some quotes and back
in 2014 a lot of these like motivational
quote accounts were very like popular so
I would take these quotes and then I
just uh you know uh the description or
the caption underneath it was like my
little journal and the account is
actually still up people can go look at
it um anything prior to I believe
September of 2016 anything prior to that
as me anything after that is the person
I sold it to or 2015 I should say I
believe uh but that was my first ever
business but weirdly enough I just
stumbled upon it
because I was reading a lot of books at
that time and for me it's not like I
really had too many people my age I
could speak to or talk to about these
sort of things uh that Instagram account
was very cathartic for me it was my way
to basic journal and you know I started
building it up and it got to a point
where one day I got a DM from someone
and they were like oh you know can I buy
your account or you know can I buy a
promotion and I just thought it was the
weirdest thing ever I didn't know that
existed and then I got pulled into the
whole world of telegram groups buying
selling Instagram accounts promotions
this that and um basically that was my
first ever business and you know that
did well for six months a year and then
it got super super saturated you know
kind of like crabs in a bucket
everyone's just started undercutting
each other
and then I started getting really into
the gym and I you know I got really into
gym I studied all the books I learned
the difference between you know your
lumbar your thoracic your cervical like
you know all these little just you know
all this little uh minutia and these
little details and then I started uh let
me see I started selling my friend's
parents on Personal Training Services at
15
um and yeah I did that and then I
started youtubing
and at first and it's weird because
there's not many people where you can
look back to 2015 just you know you can
look back at 2015 2016 videos and I'm
like yeah like I hate taking the bus
because you know under the age of 16 you
know in London oyster cards take the bus
it's free yeah so I was taking the bus
and I just hated the bus there was
always weird people on the bus like
always and um you know I was talking
about how much I hate the bus and you
know hopefully won't you know soon I'll
be able to afford to like take Ubers and
all this stuff and this is like when I'm
16 and I
from starting a YouTube channel making
decisions to our YouTube channel I
started learning about photo video so
you know that's basically my background
my background is in photo video and
that's why
um you know if you look at my Instagram
uh if you look at YouTube like I have a
very good sense of visual and you know
that kind of parlayed onto my team and
stuff like that
so that was then the Catalyst to
starting my creative agency some agency
when it first started was a creative
agency we would do photo video work for
uh you know big businesses that got
their series a series B round of funding
and
yeah um you know I did that when I was
16 August 16
um August 2016 so I signed my first
client
uh by the time that uh summer how old
were you when you signed your first
class 16 16. so a year later
um you know I was doing between 50 and
20 000 a month
um so yeah that was pretty good but I
mean there was an eight-month Drive
spell where I didn't sign any clients
and then I signed three clients in one
week and I've noticed that over the
years it's you don't usually get wins
you know I'll say when it rains it pours
yes you know and that applies to both
wins and losses usually get your wins
clumped in in one little ball and then
same thing with your losses and you know
especially when you get your losses
you're like
you wonder if it's ever going to end and
you know when you get your wins
um you know you feel like you're on top
of the world and you're going to stay
there so I guess that was also another
thing that I've a little wisdom I've
learned over the years is um you know I
never get too elated when I've got a lot
of wins because I know at some point you
know the pendulum is going to swing
so that was summer of 2017 and then it
was great but I'm a very I guess if you
look at me on social media I'm a logic
person right like if I don't fare well
expect or especially in the world of
business I don't farewell
um with by the way this is a topic that
I'm more than happy to talk about later
this is also a big part of why I I'm not
open to uh you know I'm not against it I
have a lot of females that work for me
but I'm very against or I'm I have a
tough time with feminine energy in the
workplace right and and I've also had a
lot of men that are very feminine in
their Essence and that has every single
time caused me an issue in business
because unfortunately in business as you
know you can't
emotion and feeling and what you think
is the case you know can lead you astray
a lot of times so you know the reason I
say that is because a lot of my clients
because obviously the creative and you
know creative industry as a whole is
very uh oh I feel like it's working I
feel like it's not working and you know
there's no way that I could have a
clear-cut Roi when it came to my clients
you know they'd say what's the ROI on
this I'd be like I have no idea but I
can tell you what our reach is what our
engagement is I don't know where is your
Red Bus ads you're running and you're
spending 15 000 pounds a month on tube
station ads and red but like they can't
tell you anything it was very
frustrating for me so I basically
decided you know [ __ ] this
um I'm changing the agency Mall we're
going to advertising and we're doing
online advertising because then then
that way we can have some sort of
discernible Roi and I don't care if the
client had an argument with their wife
or their husband I don't care what the
hell happened in their life at the end
of the day they can be in as bad mood as
they want but we made the money we know
we they know we made them money they can
see we spend this much we made this much
and there's no like ifs ands or buts
about it so um yeah that's when I
pivoted and that was really when the
agency took off started hitting fifty
thousand sixty thousand eighty hundred
thousand dollar a month
um so yeah I was when I was 18 years old
there's so much to go through okay
um let's talk about the feminine energy
thing I want to pick you off on that
because that's really interesting so you
don't like working with women I I don't
mind working with women if they know how
to park that feminine
side of themselves at the door right and
as I said it's not because I think
people get very upset when you know you
say uh women are men the feminine energy
and as there's a lot of men that I've
worked with that are very in their
feminine and they are uh it's proven
time and time again not only are they
the ones that are uh the least
performing in my type of company bear in
mind if I had an HR company
totally different story if I had to
create you know if I had a true like
creative based or you know fashion
company totally different story I'm just
speaking from my personal experience and
in the line of work that I'm in you know
running a software company e-learning
company you know uh running the
advertising business
it's um in that line of work you can't
have I feel this or that and um you know
I will never ever have an issue with
someone for their beliefs I have an
issue with people when I question their
beliefs and they can't give me a real
reason as to why they've come to that
conclusion you know I um
it's funny I
I this upsets some people but I I like
to sort of poke fun of people feminazis
yep uh you know I I like calling uh
people feminazis
um because I like to see their reaction
and how they take it and uh all this
stuff I can sit across the table from a
feminazi and you know if she if she
gives me or if he gives me um
good valid points and how they've come
to those conclusions you know I think
it's absolutely ridiculous and asinine
for people to believe that uh eating a
plant-based diet is a healthy way of
living and uh also you know the way they
do vegan farming is is so bad for the
Earth and you know all this stuff but if
I can sit across from someone and they
can tell me honestly hey this is why I
believe this and I've come to these
conclusions
we could be very close friends you know
I don't think that's great you know I
don't mind it
um so yeah I that's just been my
personal experience in the past and by
the way I have a lot of females that do
work for me
um but they understand that uh some of
the emotions and whatnot in my
particular industry they're gonna have
to leave that at the door and they're
gonna have to put on their logical
critical thinking cap so enough has
taken whatsoever because I agree with
you I actually had a conversation with
my brother this morning and I said you
know what Gideon I don't know if I can
take another female client that's what I
said to him because
there's a lot of things that need to be
done right um in order to get to where
you want to be
um and those are things which don't
require emotion and if you bring emotion
into it then you're not going to get
there
um so I literally said I don't know if
this girl doesn't sort herself out I
don't know what I'm gonna do
so yeah I understand
um so and I hear you talk a lot about
um being the modern day entrepreneur
digital marketing um you know working
remotely Outsourcing
um Outsourcing work contractors so how
does that work how does somebody you
know work remotely how do they Outsource
their work how do they find contractors
you know in places all over the world
well I mean basically what it comes down
to it and I think a lot of people
I think a lot of people look at what
I've accomplished or what other people
accomplish in this space and they're
like that can't work that's not real
that's not possible and it's like yeah
100 if I if this was the 80s and 90s
this would not work what I'm doing would
not work
um
it's just the world we live in has
afforded us certain luxuries you know I
have the luxury of hiring someone who is
a 9 out of 10 skill level for fifteen
hundred dollars who makes 750 currently
in Brazil working at an agency where
they have to commute an hour to and from
work and I get to hire them for 1500 so
they get a hundred percent pay increase
and whereas if I wanted to hire that
person you know and in my city and they
have to come into office I might need to
pay him let's say you know when I was
still living in London between uh you
know uh taxes and all that other stuff
and uh you know insurance and whatnot
I might have to pay him three three and
a half thousand pounds four thousand
pounds right so I can get talent and
they may only be a seven out of ten
skill set so I get to hire Talent
globally
and that's one of the biggest you know
competitive advantages you could ever
have and that is one of the big
advantages when you have a remote team
and I've had a remote team since
basically since since the beginning and
you know even with my agency back in
2018 I used to
you know uh Into Summer of 2018 I
basically made the decision we're not
doing any more uh meetings uh in person
because one of the things I found in
person and you know I had meetings in in
2017 I was uh traveling quite a bit uh
even for meetings I had I particularly
remember every time I would go to
Holland the culture there is you sit
down and you have a coffee and then
middle of the meeting you have a coffee
and then at the end of the meeting
you'll have a coffee as well and by the
end you've had three coffees it's been
two hours you could have finished that
conversation in 25 minutes yeah it was
so unnecessary it's all this extra talk
it's all this extra bureaucracy and I'm
just not that kind of person
so um you know I made the decision in
2018 that we're going strictly Zoom
meetings uh you know two years before it
became popularized yeah so that's the
benefit is when you can sign clients you
know nationally or you know in my case
it was all across the world and you can
also hire Talent
yeah you know all across the world then
you have a massive massive competitive
Advantage right there and really all it
is is arbitrage it's there's Arbitrage
because you can hire a talent that's
incredibly good and you're also changing
their lives because in the you know
they're able to work with a company
that's earning in a stronger currency
and they get to get to paid get to be
paid you know twice three times
sometimes four times as much as they're
currently making and then you get to
work with you know companies that are in
uh you know some of these more wealthy
um countries and you know a lot of times
you're also able to provide the service
for cheaper than uh you know any other
quotes that they're getting so that's
why this sort of stuff works basically
so how important do you think it is then
um to be able to make money online do
you think it's going to be you know if
you don't innovate you're going to be
massively left behind so speaking of
making money online what good is the
internet if you can't access the
information needed to start a business
because of increasing censorship that's
why I want to tell you about a project
that I'm really excited about called
tominet censorship is increasing and a
major war on freedom of speech and
information is on its way this is why I
believe in an alternative internet
called tominet Tommy net is a
decentralized parallel internet where
anyone in the world can access the Tommy
net web browser regardless of government
restrictions basic human rights like
freedom of speech and information is at
the heart of what I discuss on this
podcast and Tommy's principles now back
to the interview you know I think a lot
of people want to [ __ ] on traditional
businesses I think traditional
businesses are great it's just uh it's a
harder skill set and I will not sit here
and say that you know I'm this genius
entrepreneur and you know when I was 18
years old I could have started a
successful
a successful I don't know a roofing
company I couldn't have I didn't have
the money uh I also don't think I was a
good enough entrepreneur to deal with
in-person
um employees uh to deal with the
headache the over you know the stress of
the overhead and all the stuff like
you know there's a lot of business
opportunities and
I kind of explained this uh recently I
closed down my agency I closed down two
of my companies because there's just too
much piling on at the moment and my main
focus on my main business right now is
my software company and I had
opportunities to start my software
company in 2018 and 2019 and I just knew
I wasn't ready like I knew that was a
business that required a 9 a 10 out of
10 skill set it's the most difficult
business I've ever been involved in and
I've been involved in a lot of
businesses and it also takes a lot of
money you know I had to personally sink
in a lot of money
um you know to actually start my
software company with my business
partner so I think it's just the online
world is a fun little playground uh and
you can kind of play around in that
little uh sand pit and there's so many
ways that you can kind of get your foot
through the door if you know for any
entrepreneur in the 70s I would have
said yeah maybe it's not worth the risk
for anyone in the 70s who had to take
out a two hundred thousand dollar loan
in order to start their business a lot
of them I would have said to be honest I
don't think you're gonna make it and I
don't think it's worth the risk to even
try and that sounds Bleak but it's just
the longest truth whereas the world we
live in in 2022
there's no reason why you shouldn't try
because what's the cost you know let's
say you want to be a online service
fighter I mean there's a hundred
different ways you can you know you can
do things whether you want to be a tick
tock editor whether you want to be you
know a perfect example
there's certain people obviously you're
very good on camera there's some people
who aren't good on camera but they would
love to start a podcast so instead
rather than you doing all the research
you can have someone else who is your
researcher you know they're behind the
scenes they do the 40 hours of research
on a guest before they come in they do a
one hour brief with you so that way you
don't have to spend that time for you
that's easily worth you know a couple
thousand dollars a month and they can do
that if they don't have the correct
skill set that they need so that's an
example I mean you know this is 101
different examples that you can use and
the best part is if you have a skill set
and if you develop a skill set or you
find a way to provide value to the
market you also have the entire Market
whereas 10 20 30 years ago you had a
little sliver of your city or maybe you
know your state or your country whatever
it is you know your county whatever so
um it's a very unique time that we're
living in and it I think it makes me
very upset that some people aren't
making the most of it and I will say the
other thing is
I think it's very very Noble to work I
think not only is it very Noble
but it can be very very profitable to
actually work for the right company uh
remotely as well I have employees of
mine that make half a million dollars a
year and they make they and they've run
businesses I have many many people in my
team who used to run businesses but they
literally make more money working in my
organization and they get that team
community and like aspect of it and I've
said many times if it wasn't for my team
I would have retired by now like it's
it's a very I think it's a very
depressing existence just making money
and not having anyone to like either
share with of course I've got people in
my life to share with but like to enjoy
it with you know as I told you you know
I'm taking my team and flying to a
wedding
um you know in a couple days and it's
just fun you know meeting with the team
you know uh flying on a private jet a
lot of them haven't flown private before
going to the wedding you know getting
drugged in my team hanging out a few
days after like it's just it's amazing
thing and uh that's another thing that I
will tell people is like
yes this online realm has allowed people
to start businesses but it's also
allowed really good talent to collect uh
to connect with really good companies
with amazing growth potential that are
already established
um and it just means yeah it just
there's so much cool opportunity and I I
received probably
every time I put something out on my
socials to hire a new position I get
Maybe
anywhere from 500 to 1000 applicants it
depends on sort of how Niche
um yeah it depends on sort of how uh
Niche the position is
so you know we hired 17 people in the
last month
um so I don't know I I would say I
probably get 20 000 unique applications
because a lot of people apply for
multiple different jobs I get 20 000
applications a month to work at one of
my companies uh we don't check CV we
don't check CVS and we don't ask for CVS
ever uh we go through our own very
stringent multi-step process to vet for
not only uh their abilities uh you know
that they can actually do what they say
they can do
but also culture fit and you know part
of that culture fit we've asked some
very unique questions you know we've
asked people if they've cheated on their
girlfriends or their wives oh wow we've
asked people have they been to a strip
club we've asked people
um and I'm not by the way none of those
were saying is right or I'm not giving
you answers to any of those
um we just want to see whether they're
honest you know we had a very very very
strong candidate that came to uh applied
for uh to work for us from one of our
biggest competitors and you know we were
very
Keen to have him joined the team because
it was you know probably their biggest
key player and you know would have been
a very good uh very good hire for us we
and I don't know why this person fumbled
it but we asked well actually my CEO
asked
you know uh how much money do you have
in your bank account and he lied and uh
you know my CEO was like okay cool show
me your show me your bank and you showed
him his bank and it was it wasn't the
same amount so you know just little
things like that
um you know we've asked uh you know I've
asked people on my creative video team
do you have a girlfriend yes no what do
you consider a long time away from your
girlfriend uh how much is your rent are
you splitting it are you paying yourself
I want to understand all these aspects
um of them and yeah that's that's
another thing I will say is uh I think a
lot of people are very uh skeptical of
how I've been able to get to this point
uh without my team I probably wouldn't
have been able to accomplish 10 and I
know a lot of people say that because
you know they think it sounds good uh no
I genuinely mean it like it's there's
too much [ __ ] to do in a day one person
can't manage at all like you need to
have a very good team that is
fascinating
um I love that those questions are
amazing as you were saying them I was
like answering them myself in my head I
was like is that her answer is that the
right answer
um so I was going to ask you how do you
hire so you just answered that um but
then how did you get the team because I
think hiring is really hard I think like
finding the correct match is really
difficult um you know having those
values aligned obviously is important
um but you have the team in place first
so how did you get them in place because
it sounds like they are you know the
foundations of everything that's going
on well I mean the team is kind of it's
in the same way
your dating options you know if you work
on yourself as the years go by you have
more and more dating options the same
thing when it comes to hiring you know
don't think that
you know when as a guy when you first
start and you know you're still living
at home with your mom and there's
nothing particularly wrong with that but
let's say you're living a home with your
mom you're just decided look I'm going
to turn my life around I'm going to
start a business or I'm going to be a
part of a fast-growing organization and
provide so much value to them that I get
paid very handsomely
that first step you know you're you're
not going to have the abundance with
women that you want right but five or
ten years down the line you might and
it's the same way with hiring everyone
thinks that oh I'm hiring them I'm
paying them they should be lucky like I
realize every single person that I hire
we have to do a very we have to have a
very conscious effort to curate the
culture in a way where we're selling
ourselves to them right like once it
gets to the uh the actual hiring process
they're selling themselves to us because
they already know the culture of the
company everything like that
but prior to that like you need to hire
people need to uh go through the hiring
process in the same way that they go
through getting new customers it's just
as important now bear in mind this is
also me you know in my position where
you know my companies do
my software company I can't talk too
much about because a business partner
but well over eight figures a year right
so it's it's a big organization and it's
a big structure
when I first started and you know my
first employee of my agency uh Danny
he was just a contractor that was
working with
you know three four hundred dollar a
month uh local clients in Colombia uh
you know doing ads for coffee shops and
stuff like that and we basically spend
you know we had an incredible four-year
Journey where we went from that to uh
him being a contractor then joining me
full time
and then us working on our skill set
training starting to you know sign some
very big clients for us at the time uh
clients like uh ordering if you know who
that is uh it's like a wearable
Fitness tracker oring
um Kevin Rose who's like a very big
investor
um you know very big clients back in
2018 specifically uh those are some of
the highlights and
yeah we just went through that journey
together he eventually ended up becoming
my CMO ran ran the company uh and you
know we were selling very very good
terms and whatnot so
I guess all that to say that you're not
going to be able to hire the talent that
you want to hire to begin with it's it's
a process just like anything in your
life
um hire who you can now try to work on
the company ask yourself why would
someone even want to work at this
company outside of money because
especially you know the last two years
it is a
you know last two years it's um you know
employees Market you know it's um
there's a shortage of talent and um I
guess that's one of the other
interesting things about the way that
the world is uh and everything going
online I'm used to this stuff I'm used
to hiring the best of best talent all
across the world uh and now the best of
best talent all across the world is
realizing oh wow it's really cool I can
work for a company remotely and I can
still have my life and you know my
employees I tell them I'm like look if
there's weeks you need to work 10 hours
work 10 hours I don't want you to work
40 hours there'll be weeks where you
need to work 70 hours and don't you ever
[ __ ] dare hold against me because I
won't hold it against you when you're
working 10. don't hold against me if
there's a week you need to work 70 and
that's kind of our culture and a lot of
people really like that and a lot of
people like that they can you know I
don't tell them hey you have to go to
the gym at this time because you have to
be in office so
yeah you know it's uh I said it's it all
comes down to where it's a very
interesting Market we're in at the
moment both for opportunity for
employees for employers
you know the game's changed in the last
uh in the last 10 years but specifically
the last two three years yeah the game
has changed so much
um and I like that you mentioned the
whole entrepreneur like the this you
know the second best person at the
company who can make tons of money um I
don't think that the entrepreneur gets
enough credit it's always the
entrepreneur I mean there's someone in
my uh company who literally went from
there's someone in my company that hired
someone to do parts of what he was doing
so he didn't have to do anymore so he
has a team of three vas and he went from
making 12 000 a month to 25 000 a month
and I was like you're you're very smart
like this is you know and that's so you
definitely can be an entrepreneur in the
right company it just depends on whether
you know the company stifles that growth
or whether that company
um you know is okay with it or they're
not so it's all really about finding the
right organization
speaking of how the world is changing um
I saw your YouTube video
um I think it's my seven million dollar
crypto portfolio video so I saw that I
thought damn how does this guy have all
this money to start investing
um so I'm curious how did you get
involved um with crypto and in terms of
putting that passive income into
um investing like what's your strategy
how are you navigating all of this
so that's that video was pretty funny I
think I was the first person to actually
because a lot of people kind of talk
about their uh investment portfolios or
like they talk about uh their crypto
portfolios uh but they'll never very a
lot of people talk about uh crypto but
then not many people actually say how
big their portfolio is and you know even
fewer will actually prove it right so I
it was a it was a massive ball Lake to
get everything off of cold storage and
this and that and ready for the video
but yeah I had my 6.8 million dollar
crypto portfolio and that was in May I
think the video uploaded like mid May
2021 or something like that you know I
found it hilarious three days later
markets crashed that 7 million was worth
three and a half million everyone was
just flaming me in the comments
um yeah I don't know I I found it pretty
funny but that 7 million portfolio
like look I wish I could say you know I
sat here I wish I could sit here and say
you know I'm a genius or this or that I
just took a bet on crypto I had a
million dollars sitting uh in my agency
bank account and I'm like well a little
bit more than that but I'm like you know
I'm just gonna take a million
and I'm just gonna throw it into crypto
because right now I saw uh you know the
money Printing and if you look back
historically the best time you know once
they start printing money it once they
start uh printing money that's when you
want to start uh invest investing in
assets because all that money ends up
flowing through into the assets usually
and that's exactly exactly what happened
I mean you saw crypto go up you saw real
estate you go up you saw you know things
that I'm really into for example watches
they went you know astronomic I mean
even cars uh you know you've got uh you
know G wagons you got G63 that's going
80 100 000 over a sticker a used one
it's you know I know a lot of that came
also came down to like this uh supply
shortages and stuff like that but it was
a crazy once again it was just one of
those crazy environments that we lived
in so I put a million dollars uh in
December 2020 into Bitcoin uh at the end
of the month or early January 2021 I
rolled that all into ethereum and I held
that for uh probably a few weeks like
six weeks and then I you know I had a
bunch of friends uh in the space and you
know
a lot of it was just kind of at first in
the first like two three months was just
kind of listening to him blindly they're
like no no put some money into cardano
oh put some money into this that and
like At first I'm like putting into
money in cardano and and I didn't even
know what it was and you know at a
certain point I had you know a million
dollars in cardano and I'm like I should
probably learn you know what's a layer
one what's a layer two what does this
actually do the whole ecosystem
so uh yeah uh you know uh long story
short that million dollars in principle
turned into seven million and it went
down to 3.5 uh and at that point I knew
a little bit more about the crypto
markets I made the decision look I'm
gonna stick to this I don't think that
um you know we're officially bare uh
stuck through it and uh also learned my
lessons when it came to profit taking
and I would say by far the biggest issue
making money in crypto if you get in at
the right time is not difficult
it's can you keep those profits and that
was the thing that I that was a skill
set I hadn't yet learned at that point
and uh yeah but next time that um uh you
know by the time November came around I
was taking more profits uh I still think
I you know a lot of it I left too late
and now looking back was very Reckless
like for example uh you know I had some
money in Luna and my conviction uh in it
um you know that only fully came to an
end at the beginning of April uh which
also happened to be the absolute top so
I sold two and a half million dollars
worth of that oh wow before the crash
yeah I um that was the other thing I
realized I'm never ever going to talk
about crypto publicly ever again because
that's not my domain as in like that
people got so upset it was just so
interesting to see because everything I
do in my life I just share and you I'm
not saying you should do it I'm not
saying follow along I'm not a crypto
like it's just everyone kept asking like
oh what's going with your portfolio
what's going on with your portfolio
sometimes I put stuff on Insta like
you know right at the end of October
2021 I put hey I'm putting a million
dollars into Luna and then uh it was I
think the day before Christmas so
December 23rd 24th something like that
I'm like hey uh that million was then
worth two and a half I believe and I'm
like look I'm taking my principal out
right very I said unlike uh early in the
year I'd learned some wise investing
this uh you know Wise investing
principles and I realized okay take the
principle out I'm leaving us everything
else in
I didn't feel like I particularly had a
you know moral social responsibility to
then tell people oh April 3rd I took out
my remaining 1.8 million like that's not
my domain you know like that's not
yeah you know there's definitely things
that I do in my life where I feel so I
need to inform people for example When I
close down my agency I could have very
easily just not mentioned it but I'm
like I'm closing it down for this reason
this reason Etc et cetera this is why
this sacrifice I'm having to make for
such and such like that's my realm I
know crypto is not really my um yeah
it's not my life's calling so uh yeah I
think people got very very upset at that
they're like oh you never told us you
sold your Luna I'm like I'm not a crypto
influencer
um so yeah I think definitely next time
round that's one another lesson I
learned which is just in general the
crypto is a very
it's a very um it can be a very toxic
space and it's I will be continuing to
invest in crypto
um you know I've got my um I've got my
orders set you know I've had some
fulfilled recently
um you know I've got orders set all the
way down from 18K all the way down to
14.
um Bitcoin yeah Bitcoin I'm only buying
Bitcoin right now I only buying Bitcoin
yeah I would not touch anything else in
a bear Market there's no point really
right because Bitcoin dominance is just
gonna continue to go up
I don't think the economy is going to
get any better anytime soon so you know
the faith in or at least at the time
recording this you know the faith in the
crypto Market is already you know not
super high so then you know to be
investing in ethereum and I saw a lot of
people going into the merge you know but
I mean of course idiots will always be
idiots right yeah you know uh putting
the life savings uh in and you know of
course it dumped after so for me I'm
buying Bitcoin that's it and um
yeah once the market stabilizes a little
bit more which I don't think is for now
anytime soon uh then of course you can
start rolling into ethereum and then you
know some of the the top 20 30 50
altcoins but for now safe and simple
Bitcoin which I always roast people that
invest in Bitcoin in a bull market right
because I'm like why
if if bitcoin's going up everything else
is going up you know multiple fold more
uh but in a bear Market yeah I the same
principle applies if things are going
down bitcoin's gonna go down but
everything else is going to go down
multiple times more so yeah I'm just
being very uh boring and sensible right
now with my crypto Investments well I
think it's a small idea um yeah I agree
hitting that sell button and taking
those profits is the hardest thing
um and yeah actually crypto is one of
the most toxic Industries if you just
say a word like if you just say cardano
right it means suddenly you know you're
promoting it and now you're responsible
you are responsible for everyone and
everything yeah so yeah you have to be
you have to be really careful with that
um so we say Bitcoin is your favorite
coin you know do you care about Bitcoin
or is it just sort of like a financial
investment to be honest and I know this
will pass off a lot of people as well
like I was very I was very in the world
of or in the thinking of okay
crypto is a form of Savior and the more
and more I think about it uh the more
and more I think about it the less and
less conviction I have that I will be
invested in it and you know you might be
able to clip this in 10 years and go
look at that idiot but uh the less and
less conviction I have about it past 20
25 2026 about crypto or Bitcoin crypto
okay
look crypto is a technology right so the
technology I think 100 but
I don't know I think about it and I
think everyone looks at it as this
revolution against the government and
half of me believes that the other half
of me believes uh you don't beat the
elites you know you don't believe uh you
know you don't you don't beat the elites
you don't beat the um you know the
central banks you don't beat you know
basically the Puppet Masters and
part of me is like um is this one of
their plans to create something out of
nothing
swallow up all of this value for
something that is technically valueless
and you could say the exact same thing
about the US dollar but you know the
only reason the US dollar has its value
is because of the US Army without the US
Army there is no US dollar in my
personal opinion and all you need to do
is look at all the wars started and name
a piece and that basically tells you the
US dollar the only thing that's it's
backed up by is its Army in my opinion
um so
I'm I'm in 50 50. you know I'm in two
minds about crypto but what do you mean
so do you mean crypto or Bitcoin though
I mean Bitcoin I mean you mean the whole
Space you think like Bitcoin really
could be created by let's say like the
world economic forum and they did it so
that they could they could just swallow
swallow yeah yeah correct yeah and and
look everything's everything is there on
the blockchain and that is you know
Regulators of dreams right so it's you
know I mean there's certain things I'm
I'm a massive fan of um you know like
Monero uh and I like privacy uh coins
and privacy tokens and stuff like that
um but when it comes to as I said I'm
that's some there's there are things
that I am dead set on I know I've done
my research and I'm I'm I've formed my
opinion this is one where I'm 50 50. you
know if you ask me
you know eight months ago it would have
been a different story now I guess I
just look at things and I think the
other thing is I will say is as you
start to get further and further along
the journey you start to
you know I always wonder I'm like why
the hell would any billionaires invest
in bonds that makes no sense to me but
then you start to realize it's not a
certain level it's not just about
offense it's about defense and it's
actually primarily about defense
and I always tell people I'm like you
know until you get to around 5 million
it should be for the most part or at
least once you get to to get to a
million should pretty much be almost all
offense after a million maybe a little
bit of Defense once you get past sort of
25 million then it needs to be a lot
more defensive thinking especially when
it comes to Investments because you know
uh my businesses produce very good cash
flow and they produce very good money
and
I don't know I guess maybe that's made
me also a little bit more paranoid about
certain Investments and thinking
you know what if it's not what it seems
so yeah I will say
certain things I have strong conviction
on uh with this uh you know don't take
it don't take it as gospel because uh
maybe I'm just projecting my own
paranoia no I hear you when it comes to
something like ethereum
um
but Bitcoin I don't think so I feel like
there's such an attack on bitcoin and
proof of work the mechanism which
obviously secures the network you know
and they sort of dress up with this
whole environmentally climate change
yeah
that sort of so I think bitcoin's
different
um but but I I don't know
um
what's your take on centralization
versus decentralization
uh they both have their pros and cons I
mean once again if you look at in the
realm of crypto centralized platforms uh
you know uh centralized platforms you're
gonna get a much better user experience
than some of the D5 platforms but then
there comes the risks you know
Associated to having a centralized
entity
um you know same thing with you know
even looking at ethereum compared to
bitcoin
some have you know they have their Pros
they have their cons so it's
you know I'm not leaning one side or the
other I think
you know if you are like a true crypto
purist
I do believe everything needs to be
um a decentralized like otherwise
there's really
there's to me that's the whole point of
crypto but uh you know a lot of things
that are built for a certain intention
over time just kind of morph uh and I
think that's kind of happening in crypto
right now
yeah I think um decentralization is
better centralization creates a better
user experience brings more people in
but then it's gonna swallow it so yeah I
think it's a pretty interesting one um
let's move on a little bit I want to
talk about the last two years
um am I right in saying that when you
moved from Dagestan to London you sort
of called London Euro adopted home that
was the idea yeah and you were really
grateful for everything that London had
given you but you then decided to leave
London so what happened why would you
leave your new adopted home you moved to
Dubai why Dubai what happened so I guess
here's the other thing I don't hold a
Russian passport actually
um I was in the process with my uh
lawyers and tax advisors and stuff like
that I was in the process of getting my
Russian passport just because I like to
have as many passports as possible and
then everything started happening and I
was like you know okay let's let's uh
let's revoke the application and um and
I actually have to spend a little bit of
money in order to do that because it was
farther along so you know I it's not
like I hold a you know obviously it's
impossible to hold a UAE citizenship
um you know I have no attachment there I
don't really feel any particular
attachment to Russia but the interesting
thing is I have a British passport I
have had a British passport for a long
time it's my main passport
I never call myself British I don't
consider myself British and I would
never dare uh for me I think there's I
love International the international
aspect of the world but I think there is
something to be said about knowing where
knowing what soil you're from and also
just respecting the fact that you're I
don't care how long I lived in the UK
for me personally I could never call
myself British I don't have British
blood you know my blood is actually
primarily Persian fully enough you look
at actually you look pleasure I I get a
Persian and a little bit of Italian so
yeah yeah
um so that's where my blood is from but
even though I came to London I would
never call myself British uh and I think
the reason I mentioned that is because I
I think maybe that made it a little
easier to leave because I didn't feel
like oh I'm British you know I'm
betraying my country or this or that
like I always felt grateful to the UK
and I love the UK you know I will say
London is turning into a bit of a [ __ ]
hole
and if you asked me two months ago I
wouldn't have said that and I think that
was because I love this city so much
it's been so hard for me to finally be
like okay yeah it is a bit of a show uh
and yeah it's it's kind of sad to see
what happened there but um you know I
could say a lot about UK police and I
can say a lot about
um sort of gun laws and uh just how
ridiculous gun laws are and why I
believe the UK is a perfect example of
why the police 100 for a fact need guns
because no one's scared the police I'm
not scared of the police I've had many
times you know during uh the shutdowns
we'll call them um would you want to
call them uh I think shutdowns will be
easier
for your YouTube channel
um you know for the shutdowns many times
I had uh you know police officers coming
to my house and you know I
because I would have you know friends
over I had my chef over I'd have I'd be
enjoying life I'd be living life I mean
uh I don't know if you remember there
was one Christmas and I'm never in
London in the winter but there was one
Christmas they were like oh you can't
they tried to cancel Christmas yes I
remember like are you [ __ ] crazy uh
so yeah I had a I had a very very nice
Christmas party and all this stuff so
yeah I would have police officers coming
to my house
um and ones that came to my house and
were like look
this is ridiculous I don't really want
to be here but could you just you know
they were just very spoke to me like a
human
I was always very polite to them I was
like you know look let me you know draw
the shades you know let me try to turn
music down let me just you know be a
little less obvious stuff like that but
some people just came in with such an
attitude and the amount of times I had
uh you know the offices came in with an
attitude yeah yeah the amount of times I
had police uh and they were like oh can
I look inside I'm like no you can't and
they were like oh how many people are
inside there I'm like six and I was like
40 people inside and uh they're like can
I look inside I'm like you most
certainly cannot get off my property
um and of course you how are you gonna
be scared of a you know five foot seven
obese guy with a baton like I don't know
like the UK police is not very menacing
they're not very scary and you know even
you look at watch crime
which is absolutely horrific in London
what are the police going to do and and
you know you've got a situation where
you've got
um a lot of times these illegal
immigrants and I'm in a group an
immigrant the legal one yeah I just yeah
exactly I don't happen to be an illegal
immigrant um so I understand how the
opportunities that come with you know
living in uh UK London all the stuff I
understand how difficult it can be but
you know you've got these illegal
immigrants or a lot of times just even
people who were born in UK and you've
got a situation where if they're selling
drugs they might go to and they're
caught they might go to prison for 10
years 15 years 20 years whereas if they
rob someone of their watch uh I think
the prison sentence is five years for
theft and they'll get out after two and
a half and you know to sell you know
let's say they
steal a Rolex off someone's wrist you
know it's a a precious metal piece you
know that might be 30 000 let's say you
know they find some knucklehead with a
Patek Philippe that's just walking along
the street you know uh with his air pods
in being a bit of an idiot you know that
could easily be a hundred thousand a
hundred thousand pounds right there to
make that sort of money dealing drugs is
you know is you know much different
story so
yeah you know it's um I looked at the
way London was going in London when I
made the decision it wasn't quite that
bad you know I remember back in 2019 I
would be walking
back in 2019 I'd be walking down the
street you know wearing uh you know a
nautilus I'd be wearing a royal look I'd
be wearing you know 100 000 pound
watches no issues even in 2020 it wasn't
really that bad I'd be walking down the
street with a sharp Mill
um
and yeah I mean of course I knew there
was still crime but it wasn't like tense
like now London is like tense like
everyone knows you don't wear a watch
like
yeah it's I don't wear a watch and even
you know I was also one in 2019 2020 my
friends were like you're an idiot what
happens if they take them like whatever
if they take it I knew the risks like
but I it just it didn't feel that bad
now when I go to London I'm like
yeah even I'm on edge so um you know I
don't wear anything while I'm out there
so
you know one of the big reasons why it
comes uh comes that stage is you know
basically just the wealth disparity and
you know as the the gap between the rich
and the poor just gets worse and worse
and it's so annoying because it's it's
very sad to see because obviously I come
from a background where you know my mom
was on government benefits she used to
also used to work at um NHS Chelsea and
Westminster Hospital she used to be a
receptionist so I also got a very
interesting insight into
um the NHS the funding also how people
would sort of abuse the NHS because a
lot of people in the UK actually abuse
the services
um so it's just the whole thing is very
very interesting I had a very
interesting perspective on on the UK but
um
you know it's unfortunate that a lot of
uh you know the lower class look at the
wealthy people and are like this is the
reason why we have this wealth divide
and it's getting worse and worse and
they don't realize it's their government
it always comes back to government
you've got a situation now where in
Germany people are paying five five six
seven times what they were paying last
year for energy whose fault is that
that's the government you think that's
the you know the wealthy person that
went from you know um School deciding to
start a local store then that become
becomes a you know National supermarket
chain and now is worth 700 million euros
that's not his fault that energy prices
are going up it's the [ __ ]
incompetent government so it's just very
and I think that's
like I think in the next year you're
going to see it in London and this is
why I'm so grateful I live in Dubai
you're going to see it in London I think
you're going to see in New York you're
going to see it and you're already
seeing in a lot of different cities
especially in Europe really I'm talking
Purge level civil unrest because it's
gonna get pushed to the point where the
lower class just have nothing left after
paying for fuel after paying for energy
you know they were taught they kept
saying they kept you know saying or for
the last few years dark winter dark
winter
and at first when they were saying dark
winter because they always like to in
you know the cabal and uh you know all
the evil at least they like to implant
these things ahead of time they when
they said dark winter I thought it was
going to be a reaction to the JibJab
right I thought that's what they meant
oh
when the winter came I've had to figure
out all these creative ways I go with
magic medicine but I like Jake
as you know you have to find creative
ways to talk about it so so when
uh they kept talking about dark winter I
kept thinking okay
um basically it's gonna be there's gonna
be like I'm talking millions and
millions of deaths when it came to
um you know the JibJab
um what I started to realize now is I
think this is going to be the dark
winter when they said dark winter they
meant it in the most literal sense which
is you either choose heating or
electricity and I think there's gonna be
a lot of people that are going to be
pushed to that decision this winter and
I would not want to [ __ ] live in
Europe that that's for sure so
it was obviously I couldn't have uh I
couldn't know exactly what was gonna
happen but I looked at the money
printing
I looked at the tyrannical stance of the
UK uh with a lot of the
um you know shutdown stuff
and it just felt a general sort of
discontent for UK I just kind of felt
the general level of disappointment and
I was like [ __ ] this and I was like okay
you know where you know where are my
options and I'm like look if I'm making
this big life change because it was for
me a very big life change I want to get
paid for it because I knew I was staying
in the UK and paying way too much in
taxes
so you know I start looking at some
options you know there's options for
example Italy they've got a flat 100K
year uh scheme for expats where you only
need you know if you make 50 million a
year or you make 500 000 you only pay
100K as long as the company is on Italy
so there's all these like cool and I'm
like okay cool I'm going to Italy that
sounds sick but then I thought about it
I'm like I need to be in Italy six
months a year and then I thought about
it I'm like I'm going to Italy but I'm
still going to face the exact same thing
that I left the UK which is a country
that in my opinion is not going in the
right direction tyrannical stances on
certain things
um so I looked at I'm like okay where
has dealt with this stuff the best Dubai
um yeah they got good police yeah and
they don't need police this is the
craziest thing you can leave like Dubai
is you can literally leave a million
dollars in cash on a table I leave my
apartment many times uh you know because
the door is the door's so heavy uh
sometimes it closes but I can tell it's
not closed properly and the first time
my friend saw it they're like you're
gonna leave your door open I'm like yeah
because they know I've got
stuff inside that you know it's good
stuff in there yeah I would not do that
in London you know let's go to say you
know there's um definitely some valuable
stuff in there so I'm like what's gonna
happen you know the security in the
building is is literally Top Notch it's
A1 I've never seen anything like it and
also people would know be dumb enough to
actually steal anything and if you do
get to a level where someone is breaking
into your apartment in UAE you're [ __ ]
like
you're dealing you've pissed someone off
to the level where it's not about
whether your door is locked or this or
that it's like yeah you've you've
annoyed someone where there's no
escaping it so um I love Dubai I think
Dubai is great I know a lot of people
have a lot of issues with it uh you know
they say it's a country
or you know specifically a city that was
built on slavery
um I would point to America yeah most
countries I'll point to America I'd
point to you know a lot of people who
just got very upset I'll see about um
you know the queen dying recently
I couldn't give less of a [ __ ]
um to be honest I know that's gonna
offend and upset some people uh I don't
look at sentiment I look at what a
person did
um you know and the British Monarchy I
don't
I don't know if I
I'm not judging what they did because I
probably would have done the same thing
but I'm not gonna applaud them and be
like you know uh you know they're great
people and they did so much for the
world and not like they you know raped
pillaged all of these countries you know
brought them in as their um you know as
part of their monarchy and I don't judge
it but I don't think it's necessarily
admirable or you know people should be
crying over a person that did that so um
yeah I know that a lot of people as I
said point to UAE but I just think it's
going in the right direction uh even you
know their opinion on a lot of crypto
stuff it's going the right direction as
well
and uh look there's a especially once
you get to a certain level in life
there's a level of safety like it's nice
it's nice for me not having to spend
1500 a day on security and driver in
London just to feel safe and you know in
London even for example I you know
especially if I'm staying a longer time
you know let's say three four weeks it's
nice to have an actual apartment rent an
apartment or a house you know I'm a
especially a sort of a townhouse kind of
person I can't do that in London because
I have to stay in a hotel because it's a
level of security it's an extra level of
security whereas in Dubai
you know in London I would never ever
ever go out I have to be very careful
where I go out I have to be very careful
uh when I have my security with me all
the stuff in Dubai I can walk around
willy-nilly I can walk around anytime
any hour any watch on any amount of cash
in my it's the it you know there's a lot
to be said about it and their police you
know it's so funny and do I you know you
don't see any police shootings you don't
see any tyrannical police any of this
stuff
um and I think people respect the law
there which uh definitely in the UK
people do not yeah I mean the police in
the UK are holding hands at LGBT
um parades dancing with colorful flags
and stuff so yeah and they're all like
you said obese so like you know if you
were to steal something they couldn't
exactly run off to you
um you know so that makes sense
um so but what was it specifically
though is it like was it like the
lockdown or was it a brewing of like
woke culture like what was it I don't
know I to be honest I personally look of
course you see some stuff that's pushed
but I will always be uh proud of British
people especially
um I spent some time up north in
Manchester doing a bit of boxing in
summer of 2020
I love the people there like you know
it's they don't they don't mess around
uh they say it how it is and all the
notes for sure yeah I've in general I
really like British people you know look
British people are abroad can be the
worst people on Earth especially when
they're drunk but like British people as
a whole the way that they dealt with a
lot of the woke agenda I feel as though
is is night and day difference compared
to America
so um
it wasn't so much the woke aspects of it
because I don't feel that too much when
I'm in UK
um I don't feel that woke like pressure
uh it was more just like oh crap if they
can really lock people down like this
um you know what else are they gonna try
next
um and so at that point I'm like you
know maybe it's it's time for a life
change
um so this is already on this topic I
want to delve into the whole woke thing
um I think what blows my mind about you
not only are you 22 and you've done so
much that's we've covered that but the
fact that you're so
um sort of awake to what's going on you
said several times the elites I mean if
I say this I'm a conspiracy theorist
um I lost a bunch of friends during the
last two years because you know we just
have different opinions on the way the
world is
um so how are you awake let's start that
how are you awake to uh the elites
um I don't know I think one a lot of it
comes down to
um
I think a lot of it comes down to my
upbringing once again I think a lot of
it comes down to my stepdad I realized
very early on I realized very early on
and this taught me a lot as well about
um like racism and stuff like that
um my stepdad he was Indian
right and it was like here's a of
someone who's Brown who's like you know
taking advantage or oppressing people
who are white and it wasn't this is
gonna really annoy some people but it
wasn't a case of
our skin color was our level of
intelligence and how much we had
educated ourselves and
I think knowing that I just growing up
you know being under someone's thumb
I just didn't want to experience that
growing up uh or you know for the rest
of my life so I just started educating
myself and I think I'm almost a person
that questions things a lot
um and yeah and then I think as well I
started doing a lot of research uh about
oppression in general and I also funny
enough uh one of the religions uh that
interested me the most always
um was a Jewish religion and I looked at
you know oppression in the past and then
why
from what I've seen Jewish families in
general these days flourish so much you
know
um perfect example you know your
relationship between you and your
brother is incredible a lot of families
don't have that sort of relationship and
if I was to guess actually I think I saw
your mom on your story the other day you
know you have a great relationship with
your mom that's that sort of family
Unity isn't uh you know present in a lot
of different religions and cultures and
this and that so as I was studying all
these different religions and you know
because pretty much every religion at
one point has been the oppressor and the
pressy and there's you know and I guess
the other thing is uh
where I also thought about this is
um where I'm from in Russia you know
what they did uh you know I can't eleven
nine oh yeah okay you've already
practiced all these all these like
buzzards yeah you know what they did
with
um you know a certain uh you know with a
certain event
um eleven nine they
that was that Playbook was taken from
Putin right because they actually did
that
um in Russia they had basically there's
uh I think there's two buildings that
went down uh in Moscow and they blamed
Dagestan where I'm from so it's
interesting because even in Russia when
uh people where I'm from indexan when we
go to Moscow like they call us
basically they refer to as black right
and like and monkeys and stuff like that
right so it's just a lot of people the
more well-traveled you are in the world
the more of the world you've seen and
the more cultures you've seen you start
to realize how it always comes down to
like who
has educated themselves and usually
specifically about money so I just
wanted to know as much about money as I
humanly could so that's why when I was
younger
I was also I was always a very
um I would also be very polite to my
teachers that are polite to me but you
know a lot of my teachers were very rude
to me especially my I always remember my
economics teacher
um you know she would even just things
like you know she would talk about
quantitative easing I was like 16 7 or 7
yeah 17 years old and I was like well
you mean student from the poor you mean
you know the base uh debasing the
currency like they've been doing for
thousands of years let's not what do you
mean quantity of using why do we need
inflation why does inflation need to be
a thing why does it why do you need to
stick to your two percent of your
guidelines that's what you mean is hey
can we eat away at two percent of the um
of the poor population every single year
so
I can't tell you where it came from
exactly but I can just tell you that I
had a keen interest in money
um because growing up it was a tool used
specifically against me and my mom and
we didn't have any of it
um and I guess between that between
studying different cultures studying
that there's always been an oppressor
and a pressie studying you know I don't
know just the more of history that I
studied the more I kind of learned about
money and then obviously that led me
into learning about the Federal Reserve
and then once you learn about the
Federal Reserve I feel as though that's
kind of when the floodgates open because
you realize where money comes from and
then basically once you realize where
money comes from you're like oh okay
yeah we're [ __ ] because it's you know
all the people that call you conspiracy
theorists
if you ask them hey where does money
come from they think it comes from the
government when in fact it doesn't you
know when you hold a 100 Bill the
government is borrowing that money from
a central bank and then they're like oh
yeah but the central bank is you know
owned by the government and not exactly
all you need to do is look at you know
uh the book uh creature of a Jekyll
Island you know in 1912 I believe I
believe it was 1912 when they all came
together and created the Federal Reserve
and you know um obviously there's rumors
and Whispers of who was there but it was
pretty much all you know all the most
powerful people at the time uh including
JP Morgan and uh another very funny
interesting uh thing that most people
don't know is you know IRS was created
two years after that
um and prior to that it was considered
unconstitutional taxes personal income
tax was was uh considered
unconstitutional so
I think that was for I think I read or
started getting into that and I read
that book when I was 18 years old and
once once you start getting into that
understanding like you know central
banks where does money actually come
from then you start to realize like okay
if someone controls the world's money
supply and as from a spiritual level
money isn't everything in life far from
it uh and money from a spiritual level
money doesn't make the world go around
but from a tangible level money makes
the world go around so whoever controls
money controls the world and if the
people that control the money aren't the
government but private investors then
how can you tell me that there aren't
Elites who control the world because
they control the money supply so
like doing the history about the Fed
people just don't know this stuff it's
so crazy
um so okay let me like ask the the
question like so we're gonna hit the
nail on the head so to what extent is
this all destruction by Design
uh I think
I think the U.S 100 is I think uh I
don't know I I wonder because
part of me is like okay they're all in
on it it's all the same team but then
I'm like um
maybe it's just the people who control
the US dollar because sometimes I think
about I'm like you know is Russia
actually in the same bed as the states
and are they actually friends but then I
think about them like that sometimes
that's a mind the only thing I know is
anyone that has the US dollar is a
reserve currency is basically you know a
puppets to
you know the elites right so that is and
all you need to look at because then
once again I look at like you know
places like Syria where they try to go
off of uh you know US dollar as a
reserve currency and then obviously you
can see what happens to a country like
that
um you know in the name of Peace
um so
yeah I think it's I think there's
certain countries that are opposition
and obviously it's interesting tectonic
plates that are shifting and uh you know
definitely in 30 years the you know US
dollar won't be the world's Reserve
currency in my opinion
um and I think that's the other thing
it's a lot of it is right time right
place
I saw the West you know the West is kind
of going to [ __ ] and everyone has you
know Ray dalio just released a very
interesting book on that uh changing
World Order uh which I also looked at
and I'm like I don't know how he wasn't
killed for that because he's he's in
those camps so so yeah sometimes I look
at those things they scratch my head but
anyways
the other thing I looked at is we're
kind of coming to last 20-year life
cycle of the West as you know the
dominant power so I'm also like okay
well if the tectonic plates are shifting
and one country's about to go to [ __ ]
I'd also rather go to you know a place
where things are flourishing
and obviously you know uh China I think
will come out as probably the leading
Powerhouse but I don't particularly want
to be a part of the Communist Regime so
another place that's doing well is once
again Russia I really don't want to go
back there Middle East is flourishing uh
and I think Middle East is flourishing
and I think the Middle East is going to
take a very sort of Switzerland approach
to things
um very sort of diplomatic so yeah I
think obviously I live in Dubai because
it's the closest thing to a western City
I mean Dubai is like you can really you
know it's very uh I think some people
have the wrong idea of Dubai Abu Dhabi
is slightly different it's a little bit
more conservative and then you know if
you go to some of the um other cities in
UAE it's it's sort of the same
um you know similar places Doha it's
once again a very great place to sort of
a lot of opportunity there
um great place to set up you know far
more conservative as well and then you
know Saudi Arabia is also doing a
massive massive push so it's it's going
to be interesting and I think
um
yeah I don't think the Middle East is
going anywhere at all
I also don't believe that uh oil is
finite uh yeah I don't believe oil is
finite I do believe it is the second
most uh um second most uh plentiful
liquid on Earth
um and yeah I think it's just you know
one of their
that that's one of the things that they
try to do to destabilize the Middle East
um and some of these other countries
that they don't like is you know uh this
whole climate change agenda they used to
be global warming but they can't call it
global warming because the Earth's not
actually getting warmer so they have to
call it climate change because the
climate's always changing
so um it's yeah it's I don't judge any
of this stuff sometimes I talk about
this stuff with a very like you know
jokey or jovial
um attitude and that's because once
again everything in life if you educate
yourself correctly and I believe it is
everyone's duty to educate themselves
and um I don't believe in uh I don't
believe in oppression I don't believe in
uh or I will say I don't believe an
oppression in the Western World in if
you are from the UK the US etc etc I
believe if you educate yourself now is a
time where the playing field is more
level than ever before in the same way
if you know how to educate yourself if
you're uh you know if you don't know how
to educate yourself you're about to be
[ __ ] on you know magnitudes that you
could never even imagine
and you'll be lucky in six to eight
months if you have anything left after
you pay your your heating your
electricity you know whichever one you
decide to keep on uh you know food
prices going through the roof uh it's
it's dark for people that don't take
action yeah it's it's so crazy
um all of that is fascinating and I
agree with you on everything
um especially on the Glo the changing of
the branding from global warming to
climate change of course they changed it
um so okay so climate change
um you mentioned the feminazis
um there's also transgender which is
also this new thing in the west
um so what are the key things which you
you would say sort of wrong with the
West besides you know the police being
weak
um and then also where did that come
from like how like why why are we why
are we so unstable here uh well I mean
it's by Design like everything's put in
place by Design uh everything yeah it's
been in the last 67 years they've been
putting these things in place to
specifically destabilize because once
again I don't know this this is where
there's certain areas where I still need
to figure it out I don't know if it's by
Design to fully destabilize the west or
it was a plan to hey let's destabilize
our population so that way we can
control them but then you can control
your population but what happens when
another superpower builds up you know
their country and now you're basically
their little [ __ ] which is what's gonna
happen in in 20 years so I don't know if
it was a plan the backfire the only
thing I know for a fact is they you know
they want to destabilize the US you know
they want to focus on
um you know they want to focus focus on
left versus right black versus white uh
you know have everyone fighting with
each other uh you know they want quite
clearly they want people
to be as obese and unhealthy as humanly
possible
um they want I mean the main thing that
they want is you know men not to be men
uh and you know for that to be shameful
in any way you know it's so funny I
I asked my friend this I'm like I don't
think I've ever called someone toxically
feminine right like if if someone's in
their feminine Essence like if a woman's
in her feminine Essence I would never be
like you're too feminine how dare you be
a caretaker and you know like have this
nourishing loving energy to the people
around how dare you like you need to be
more strong like it's just weird that
you know a woman can't be toxically
feminine and I'm not talking about like
toxically feminist I mean like genuinely
like in her feminine nature
and her feminine Essence it's
interesting that a woman can't be too
feminine whereas a man once he gets to a
certain stage oh you're toxically
masculine why because I want to like
take care and provide and protect for
the people that I love both men and
women like
yeah it's um I think that's the biggest
thing basically the two the two things
they want to achieve is first of all
remove religion from the household
uh and I'm not particularly you know I'm
not specifically religious at the moment
I'm sure I will be and you know um
sometime whenever that's religion
my name is Iman it means faith in Arabic
um my family is Muslim uh I
I respect religions that are look
look I'll be on and I have people that
you know I have people in high ranking
positions in my company where we have
discourse about this sort of stuff the
one religion for me personally I cannot
get behind is Christianity
all I oh for me it just simple things
like I don't believe like the pope
tweeting you know the pope tweeting LGBT
stuff and once again I by the way I have
people that work for me that are gay I
have no issues whatsoever with gay
people it's just the way that it's
pushed especially on the younger
generations and you know at four or five
you've got kids that are being told it's
okay you can decide your gender like you
can you can take these there's not a
Christian thing that's not a Christian
thing no I understand but the point is
that the pope is in support of this you
know this uh movement that also does
stuff like that you know you've got
situations where
here you've got situations where you've
got uh what's that uh
the massive statue in Rio de Janeiro uh
oh I don't know the name of it you know
what I'm talking about though right in
the name of it
they put like vaccine saved lives on
there
oh
like
that's something so holy and something
like I just can't imagine you know that
happening in any other religion like so
for me Islam Islam is like I think
Islam's like the only religion really
holding up the holding frame you know
yeah they're not Islam is not messing
around
um
so you know I think as well once again I
think if I was
to choose a religion uh like my SM my
name literally means faith in Arabic
um so I I don't know I think I would
probably honor that uh but I've I've
been praying since the age of seven
years old like I've always believed in
God I've never ever been an Atheist uh I
I find atheism a little funny to be
honest
um well I mean it is a religion it's
just a religion you know uh it's just
the religion of science
um so I guess I don't know you pick what
your religion is at the end of the day
um
so yeah I think if uh if it came time to
it it would probably be um Islam and you
said the goal was to remove religion
from the house yeah I mean religion and
masculinity right because obviously if
you have a
you know if you have a if you have a
household that stands for you know
nothing it's you know if you have a you
know a household that stands for nothing
then it will crumble and same thing if
you have a household with no um male
figures you know the thing is I
if you look at literally any statistic
on Earth the biggest disadvantage you
can have is growing up in a single
parent household I grew up in that right
and I understood it's very very
difficult it's very very difficult
growing up without a dad and having to
learn 101 different things on your own
and having this confusion especially as
a boy what does being a man what does
that look like you know uh so I think
they basically just want to remove as
much masculinity in the house as
possible you know uh scramble gender
identity uh and you know gender roles
and it's it is just I don't know I I
understand it and I understand you know
where the whole feminist movement came
from comes from and this and that I can
understand why women think it's
empowering to go to work but for me
personally I don't think it's empowering
to go work to list basically be another
basically have another man who's your
boss and think that I have to listen
like there will be women that go to work
and you know like gospel they will
listen to their boss their male bosses
every word they're saying whether he's a
dick whether he's a not because they
have to for money
and then they go home to their husband
and they don't want to listen to their
husband you know they submit to their
boss because they feel like they have to
but then they won't submit to their
husband and by the way in all of this I
always say I mean even when it comes to
things like uh cheating I blame men for
everything
a lot of people probably would expect
them but for me if you're
wife doesn't respect you I blame the man
if you're what if your wife cheats on
you I blame the man because you know
because either
basically you weren't like it's one of
two situations either
you know the person
either the you know your partner had
some deep-rooted issues that you
couldn't see and as a man I think that's
your fault or you just got fat you got
lazy and you got uninspiring and
unfortunately you know I do believe that
um you know women are always looking for
the winner that they can settle with and
it doesn't need to mean winner today it
can be winner in future but some a man
who's driven that's why as well I find
it so funny when you know people are
like oh how do you know she only likes
you for the money and it's like I don't
know maybe she likes me for my ambition
for my drive for the fact that I started
reading a book a week when I was 14
years old maybe she likes me for the
fact that I looked my mother in the eyes
when I was nine years old and I was like
I'm gonna get us out of this hell hole
I'm gonna buy you this this this this
this and everything that I told her I
buy her at the age of nine years old
I've done I've retired her she walks
around with a fifty thousand dollar
Hermes Birkin or Kelly and you know a
Patek Philippe on her wrist and and
which funnily enough she doesn't care
about any of those stuff I tried to buy
her a G-Wagon for her birthday she was
like I don't need it why it's not
necessary but she's like she's my mom's
just like such a g that was so funny but
um yeah it's it's funny uh
you know when people say oh how do you
know that she only likes you for this or
this and it's like or how does how do
you know she only likes you for you know
that you look you know you've worked
very hard in the gym to take care of
yourself well I don't know maybe she
likes ambition maybe she likes all the
other attributes around it so um
is that a lot of these things a lot of
these problems in the world I uh I blame
men I blame men because I think as a man
you have to do your part and you can't
expect a woman to feel comfortable to
fully submit and fully feel protected
and feel like you know in my personal
opinion I think if a man is married to a
woman I'm not talking about like what
I'm not talking about like oh you know
what flavor popcorn should we have or
what should we watch tonight or
you know should we go to this holiday
destination or this holiday destination
like small things like that like I'm
talking like if if the man says okay
tomorrow we are moving to this country
for this reason and I know this is right
for our future and we do I believe a
woman should be like okay I trust my man
wholeheartedly and I am going to uproot
and go wherever he is because I trust
him so hard wholeheartedly in his
masculine energy that I know whatever
he's saying is the right decision but
that is a right that you have to earn
yeah and I think as women
um I think it is important and I think
this is taught a lot in eastern Society
um you know Eastern women can be very
um cold or appear to be cold that's
because they're always testing always
chipping away at a men's uh a manhood
and a man's masculinity to see whether
he is who you know he thinks he is or he
says he is and if she you know if he
passes all those tests then she fully
submits and she knows okay my man you
know will move mountains if that's what
it takes um as I said I think it's a as
a man you have to earn that right
um I think you are completely spot on
like as a woman that is correct yeah and
I think it's really difficult
um
to have those conversations and explain
that um it's also difficult to find that
you know because I mean you mentioned my
relationship with my brother like I
think my brother's the smartest he's
here so I think he's like the ultimate
smartest and I'm at a point with my
brother where if he's like
we're doing this probably we'll argue a
little bit you know but then I'll be
like okay I don't I'm just like okay
whatever whatever you say because he's
proven himself to me I'm like okay
you're smart clearly everything you say
everything he says is right you know
everything do you believe in a marriage
like marriage legally I'm curious I'm
curious about your opinion on sort of
stuff marriage and you know when you do
settle down with a partner where do you
want to raise your kids and uh City or I
saw you know you won a farm the other
day you know where specifically
I don't know and I think that's fine
because I want to find a man who will
know better than me so whatever he says
but that's hard because now I need to
find someone who's going to be smart
enough to know where we need to live you
know for tyrannical purposes tax
purposes all of it where we're going to
raise children I don't know and and I I
like
I interviewed somebody and he said women
are children right
and it's like you know what yeah like I
don't know I can't make that adult
decision I've made an adult decision to
be here this is good for me right now in
this country but long time I don't know
so I have to I want to find someone who
I can trust enough to say Leia we're
living there I'll be like okay thank God
you chose because I just like I don't
know yeah does that make sense
alleviates all the pressure lets you do
what you're best at basically yeah um
gives you the space to do your best at I
agree and I I really wish you know
Society was more like that I wish you
know I don't think Society has ever been
right like I don't think you know
I keep saying oh well it was better you
know back in the 60s when men were men I
don't even think men were men back then
either I think you know I think the
Dynamics were off and now we've sort of
try to fix that and we've sort of gone
the wrong way
um and I'm hoping and I actually am very
positive I do think that like the more
of these conversations that we have the
more you know lockdowns helps people
sort of you know be red pilled or wake
up to what's going on
um so I hope like we can create a new
Society like a parallel Society of these
free thinkers who who you know want to
sort of go back to the original way that
it should be
I'm curious what's it like uh dating as
someone who is very driven someone who's
very accomplished do you find it is a
net negative or a net positive
so thankfully okay so I so when I'm
dating I don't bring any work or any
masculine energy to the table like I can
I have masculine energy because I need
to like make money right I don't bring
that to the table I don't want to I'm
like oh I hope it's gonna date tonight I
get to be cute I get to be sweet you
know completely different energy right
so it's not a problem for me like men
aren't I'm not trying to compete with a
man I'm not trying to I don't know it's
all you like it's all you I'm I'm
whatever you want or you want to go
they're great that's you know I'm fully
submissive in that sense
um but it's hot so I don't have a
problem like that like men aren't
intimidated by me men aren't put off by
me the hard part is I'm just intelligent
so it's like I need a man that's more
intelligent and that becomes hard you
know
um like I've met loads of great guys but
nobody who I'm like
I trust you with my future
so I want to give my future to someone
but I I don't trust just anyone with
that
good as it should be it's a it's a
difficult one
I heard you say in a podcast you won't
settle down until you're in your 30s
uh look things can always change uh who
knows maybe I get married you know next
year of them but uh the plan uh always
even from your early age was to get
married and have kids late 30s yeah
for me it's uh
I think uh
here's why it's
the issue why a lot of men you know will
end up cheating is because they'll marry
someone you know when they're 19 or
they're 20 or 21 22
and then they'll end up getting a lot
more abundance with women and a lot more
options and then they never had a chance
to explore those options so it takes a
very very very very strong man to be 42
years old and have you know all these 22
year olds that are around or you know
just have the be in the right situations
where you've got all of this temptation
uh so for me uh you know I'd rather live
my life enjoy my life
um you know
fill out some of the chapters in my book
uh and then eventually once I do get
married
uh I will not live in a metropolitan
City because I know if I live in a
metropolitan City uh there is absolutely
no way that I don't cheat
um I mean maybe I'll be a little bit
wiser by the time I'm 38 but it just
makes things so so so difficult and uh
sometimes I do feel I've had a few
discussions with women about this
sometimes I do feel bad for women
knowing that uh
if they're with a very powerful wealthy
you know
um well-known even man and they're
living in a big city New York LA and
London whatever Paris
uh it's very
it's very rare that a man stays loyal to
his woman uh so for me I think you know
when you know that stuff uh that's why
you know I want to raise my kids uh you
know once I've closed the chapter of
um you know enjoying my life and you
know exercising my options then I want
to close that chapter and move somewhere
and raise a family properly so you don't
want to cheat you want to remain loyal
okay so here's here's the issue it also
depends what your bear in mind I come
from Eastern European background so uh
our definition of cheating is not the
Western world's definition of cheating
so
um
I for me cheating is lying or having an
agreement or understanding with someone
and going against that agreement so you
know uh if you're asking about pure
sexual monogamy
um I
definitely at this point in my life
um uh you know I would not entertain a
pure monogamous relationship uh yeah uh
it would have to be open and you know
that's kind of what I've done uh
when it comes to marriage
that's kind of why I want to get to 38
because I just feel as though once you
get once you've done so much in your
life and you've enjoyed your years and
this and that you know I do think it
does get to Stage for a man where uh I
don't think that he'll ever want to stop
sleeping with other women yeah but he'll
just be like that's a that's an old
chapter you know and um
you know whereas
men who married young and then ended up
um going on to be very successful uh I
think they're gonna have a very very
tough time being in a pure pure
monogamous marriage I don't think that's
a I think that's a recipe for divorce
personally
um but as I said
so you're Wild Oats basically as they
say so so about it that's what they say
so that you can live happily ever after
bear in mind uh yeah I come from a
Russian background so a lot of this a
lot of this even just comes straight
from my mom to be honest I don't know
what that means you come from a Russian
background what are Russians it's it's
not in Eastern Europe uh if you're with
a very if you're with a wealthy man a
very powerful man a man who has a lot of
uh options and abundance with women
um it would be ridiculous to assume that
he's not going to exercise those options
uh and in there it's not
it depends I mean it depends how um you
know this isn't to speak for all Eastern
European women uh I know honestly even
for my mom you know I've had
conversations about me
I mean my mom's a real G uh I've had
conversations with my mom and I've asked
her I'm like look if you get married
again
you know would you care if and let's say
you know the man you're with is super
intelligent super smart you feel so safe
secure you know you feel just like so in
your feminine with them uh and he's you
know awe-inspiring he's a leader he's
motivating he's you know you look at him
and you're just so in awe
and you know you also live a very very
good life he takes care of you
financially all the stuff would you care
if you know a few times a year uh you
know when he was on business trips he
slept around and he's like hell you know
my mom was like no you know I couldn't
care less because I understand my looks
are gonna fade so my looks are gonna
fade and the reason that he's with me
has got nothing to do with my looks it's
got everything to do with our shared
experiences it's got everything to do
with you know he's got a real his Queen
his Soldier by his side so you know
that's a little bit a lot of Eastern
European women are like that and you
know I will say I don't condone cheating
whatsoever
of you know for me now I guess I could
technically never cheat because uh you
know I would never get into a
relationship where I don't have the
option to exercise
um you know uh exercise things on my
side but I remember when I was 19 years
old I called my mom and this is not good
in any way former fashion but I remember
I called my mom and uh you know I was
telling her I'm a girlfriend at the time
you know I cheat on her I got caught
um only time I'd ever gone caught
um and she uh I was telling her and you
know obviously my girlfriend at the time
was very very upset with me all this
stuff and my mom just goes I don't
understand she she was with 19 year old
multi-millionaire what did she think was
going to happen oh my God and I'm not
saying that's good but I'm just saying
this is uh the way that I was raised so
um that's why knowing what I know
um I know that for right now I could not
get into a monogamous marriage but the
goal is to enjoy
my time and then eventually get into
monogamous marriage leave big cities
raise my children uh on a farm I think
that's really Noble yeah yeah I think
that's really I think that's a very fair
compromise I think um
it's it's probably not the most romantic
or poetic uh but it's at least I know
myself and I know where I am in life and
um I think that is romantic actually
because you're because you're not just
like women women forever and I will
never be satiated and it's just it has
to you know that you're like no no it's
okay one day give it you know 15 years
and 15 years yeah maybe 20 I don't know
but that's not no I I think I think it's
a noble way to look at it
um okay so my final question for you my
final topic
um so I'm gonna talk about watches I
don't know much about watches I know
you're like a crazy watch a fanatic
um you look at it you mentioned it
earlier you spoke about
um you know how uh watches went up and
all these things went up when they
started printing money um so
do you you have a correct me if I'm
wrong do you have a three and a half
million dollar watch portfolio that's
insane we're like I don't have I don't
wear watches I don't care about watches
what am I missing explain that to me
um look they're great first of all
they're great assets uh you know I uh
was recently
I was recently traveling and I took uh
ten thousand dollars cash
um and it was ten thousand dollars bang
on and that was the legal amount that
you were allowed to bring in and you
know I had a you know long-haul flight
um you know I was flying uh to us
um so it was a trip to the US and I got
there and they were
yeah they gave me uh TSA gave me such a
[ __ ] headache about ten thousand
dollars they were like if it's one
dollar more I'm gonna confiscate it and
blah blah and just like just give me so
much and I'm like dude I literally took
ten thousand dollars out this is tips
I'm literally giving this to the people
of your city like I like to have cash
because I like to tip right just because
and especially because when you live in
such a digital world you don't realize
like what month like physical tangible
money is
um and I just thought about that and I'm
like you're bitching at me for ten
thousand dollars in cash that I didn't
declare which by the way I didn't need
to declare it it was because I was
literally bang on and I'm looking and
I'm like I've also got a million dollars
right of three inches next to it in
watches and this is why I love watches
you can take a million dollars I travel
sometimes and once again bear in mind
where where I go
if I'm going to learn it I take
absolutely zero watches so it also
depends on where I'm going if I have
security the purpose of the trip etc etc
but it's great because I can take
um watches and if no matter what happens
let's say I have a situation
for some reason bank accounts get shut
down let's say uh bank accounts get shut
down bank accounts gets Frozen whatever
happens if I have watches you know this
watch right here I can take it to anyone
and you know sure I don't have my box
papers on me that brings the value down
by you know 25 I can I can still walk
out with three hundred thousand dollars
right so it's
it's a great whereas you can't do that
with cash it's not like you do that with
physical gold so for me it is a safety
net to know the you know wherever I'm
traveling you know obviously there are
specific places that I wouldn't take
watches to
wherever I'm traveling I've always got
basically my form of cash
and that's number one number two uh if
you can build relationships with the
brands now I didn't get into watches
specifically for Investments you know I
got my first ever watch when I was eight
years old on Argos on High Street
Kensington you remember like little flip
books
um so I got a Timex Expedition it was 25
pounds and um yeah I had to save up for
it and
yeah um that was my first ever watch I
was eight years old and you could uh
press the crown in and it would
illuminate and I just thought it was
like the coolest thing ever and I it
would it would be by my bedside always
and it was a quartz so I could always
hear the ticking and yeah I just it
brings back a lot of memories for my
childhood
um so you know once I started making
money in 2018 one of the first things or
like proper money where I felt like okay
this isn't just a fluke
I bought a watch you know I bought a
watch and then I started buying watches
for my friends uh you know I buy a lot
of watches for people that have been
there for me and it's a nice sentimental
thing so from a gift perspective it's a
nice thing but then also from an
investment perspective
uh they were good Investments back then
but really over the space the last
couple years and because I have
relationships with the brands
um you know there's situations where I
walk out the store and I've paid
40 45 000 pounds for a watch and uh you
know the watches were 200 000. oh well
and that's just because of allocations
right so it's a great wall you know
hobby if you can build relationships
with the brands and you know first of
all it's you know it's
the only thing is you've got to make
sure you don't sell the watches because
if they find out then the black is a
blacklist human
yeah that's the last thing on Earth you
want so if you're a genuine watch
collector I'd say it's two things
if you're a genuine watch collector uh
then why not have in my case you know
now at this point actually a four
million dollar watch collection uh I
recently picked up a very beautiful new
Patek Philippe Celestial which I'm very
excited to pick up uh so if you're like
a watch geek like me
why not have this hobby that you can
enjoy but then also you know grow
actually grow your wealth from
um but then if you're someone who isn't
a watch geek and I'd say for everyone
let's say you know you've got two
million to invest or a million to invest
just put 10 of them watches and the
benefit is
look I'll I'll be honest if you had a
you know a 50 000 Rolex Daytona on your
wrist people would perceive you
differently and if you had a Daytona
compared to let's say a leather strap uh
Patek people would also perceive
differently so I have all of these
watches and it's good because you know
I'm not gonna wear you know a red rich
or Mill to certain events because I just
look like a bit of a douchebag whereas
you know I might wear a Patek Philippe
Celestial because they're like this is
a 22 year old who's 22 year old who's
you know has a watch that's worth you
know four or five hundred thousand
dollars that is a leather strap and he's
not gonna get any like clout or like
you know um uh credit or it's not like a
cool watch to have particularly so in
certain circles you know especially
certain members clubs it's a it's a real
conversation starter
um so it's you can kind of use watches
to your advantage depending on the crowd
that you're with uh so for me it's just
and I think it's this exact same thing
when it comes to cars yeah I'm not into
cars I don't own any cars okay uh and
I'm sure it's something I'll get into at
some point but a person who drives you
know a person who drives a Lamborghini a
green Lamborghini performante is a very
different person to a person who drives
like a Bentley GT so you know there are
two different archetypes and it's also
two different sort of conversation
starters so yeah I think it's
I I don't know as guys we need our toys
so I guess just pick whatever your toys
are uh for me you know watch this happen
uh happen to my toys and you know they
do have some very strong advantages that
come with them as well that's crazy I I
didn't even know that it's like a whole
you know if you if you turn up with this
kind of strap it means this and if you
tell it what that kind of stuff it means
that but but that's to like watch Geeks
you know it's cool I get it I do I do
get it but I don't like feel it but it's
just a lot of the you know wealthy
crowds most of the time they are
horology and watch Geeks so once again
it's I think it's the same thing when it
comes to cars it's the same thing when
it comes to the way that you're dressed
um you know many different factors and
how do you store them and keep them safe
that's one of the other great things you
know it's a store three and a half four
million dollars in cars is a headache
right and then you're having to pay for
insurance and this and that for me
um you know storage is is pretty
painless it was a little bit more of a
inconvenience when I was in London
because in London uh I would be scared
to leave more than three watches in my
house so you know I have a specific
storage basically specific safes for
watches
um so that's the way I did in London I
still have a bunch there and then now in
Dubai I feel a little bit more relaxed
about leaving you know 10 watches uh in
my house so that's the best part you
know and and the you know the watches
are just super easy to to put away
whereas like the Box papers you can just
put them in storage and yeah it's a
it's it's pretty easy to maintain
honestly all right well just finally
then what's the goal for you in the next
10 to 20 years and
where can people follow everything that
you're doing I saw you're not on
Instagram today yeah I had a little bit
of a nightmare Instagram got taken down
um you're coming back oh yeah I mean
like there's always
um
yeah there's always people who
every
every six months every 12 months you
have to engage in a little bit of
Defense so I had a little bit of a
had a little bit of attack sent my way
you know four or five different things I
had to deal with that the last two days
um yeah I should be back hopefully
pretty soon but you can find me on
YouTube uh human gadji on there and then
plan for the next 10 20 years
I would honestly be lying to you if I
told you I had any clue
I don't plan 10 years out I don't plan
20 years out uh you also have like a
goal or a pup or something which is like
either you're working towards that sort
of fulfills you okay so look the only
thing I can tell you is like who are my
heroes uh I can tell you for a fact my
heroes aren't Zuckerberg or Bill Gates
like my heroes are you know Julian
Assange my heroes are
um you know he's a very divisive
character but a McAfee like keep safe
please yeah
so you know those are the people that I
look up to and um it's also crazy I was
interestingly enough I was 12 14 years
old
uh around that time I even started
telling my mom I will probably be killed
for the things I want to do in life
um so I just think
you know and another little side tangent
uh I don't want to live past the age of
72. I know some people want to live like
a hundred for me one of the best things
in life one of the best skills in life
you can have is knowing the right time
to leave the party 72 sounds about right
to me so if I could do something really
impactful and leave a legacy and for me
it would be something to do with
not going for the elites because I'm not
stupid enough to think that I can come
up against the banking cartel but just
something to leave a real positive
impact in the world and when a lot of
people talk about positive impact
they're just smoke you know blowing
smoke up their ass you know they're like
oh I donated two million to Red Cross
like you know I mean like I've I've
built five schools in Nepal
for me I don't like of course it's
amazing of course it's amazing 3 000
kids get to go to school because of me
but
this sounds terrible but to me that's
not even the Legacy I want to leave and
I'm going to continue to build schools
uh every single year but I'm talking
about like
I don't know really like dying for
something that uh is worth fighting for
like so what would be worth dying for
look for me the last two years and I'm
not ready to die yet that's for sure but
the last two years it would have been
um for example you know all of the
JibJab stuff
um you know even just looking at uh you
know uh
what uh the Kennedy was doing uh Frankie
Kennedy
um you know for me
it's a
I'm sure when I'm 60 or 70 there'll be
something that comes up where I'm like
okay this is my time to because also I
don't want to be I don't want to leave
with any money
so that I'll figure out a time where I
deploy my hundreds of Millions
leave it with your children no no no
wait wait this is podcast about to end
just give me a sec my son's not getting
anything no chance you're not leaving my
daughter will because okay but like as
women I mean you don't need more than
like 5 10 million that that's true yeah
I mean
um that's enough now but my son's not
getting anything why would he like it's
it's very depressing existence
receiving all that money all you need to
do is just look at all the lottery
winners so anyways point is I'm gonna
deploy all my capital and then I'm gonna
try to you know fight for something
worth dying for and we'll see what that
is wow Iman you are very interesting
um it's been such a pleasure I am really
I find your take on everything so
refreshing
um and yeah I'm really excited to see um
what else you do so thank you so much
for coming on the show thanks for having
me
guys if you enjoyed this episode please
don't forget to hit the like button and
hit subscribe and we'll see you all next
week